30 seconds
[Music]
I know this life meant for me yeah why
would you plan on Goliath when we got
bit David now you came in giving values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters
yes I do agree listen we finally made it
happen we have the Great
Tulsi gabbard in the house but let me
first properly introduce her background
so we can get into a bunch of topics
here together in 2002 at the age of 21
she was elected to Hawaii House of
Representatives that's 21 years old in
2003 she enlisted in Hawaii's uh Army
National Guard she was deployed to Iraq
2004 and five stationed in Kuwait 2008-9
as an army platoon officer a platoon
leader while a congresswoman she served
as a vice chair of DNC from 2013 to
2016. she was promoted to major in 2015
that's a big deal
uh she uh resigned to endorse here we go
this is when it gets interesting Bernie
Sanders campaign for 2016
Democratic presidential nomination while
in Congress she appeared on Fox to
regularly criticize and call out Barack
Obama she just wouldn't get aligned with
the entire thing so that was kind of
concerning for the other side in 2017
she was blacklisted by Azerbaijan for
taking part in visit to armenium
in the disputed Breakaway region of uh
nagorno rarabakh which is populated and
governed by Armenians as an Armenian
this was a big deal she called the U.S
Senate and president Donald Trump to
officially recognize the mass killing of
Armenian Genocide as well as the syrians
and Greeks in 1915. 2020 she ended her
presidential candidate and endorsed this
guy named Joe uh Joseph I want to say
Joseph Biden we'll talk about that as
well and she's been a fill-in for Tucker
Carlson's show many many times in
October 20 2022
she announced that she had left the
Democratic party due to a foreign policy
differences as well as some other social
issues but nobody knows what party she's
affiliated with maybe she'll announce it
today who knows in 2022 the secure
Security Service of Ukraine this is a
compliment actually placed her on a list
of public figures whom it alleges to
promote Russian propaganda another lady
also said that about two years ago I
think the challenge is to following
folks depending on who your enemies are
this could be either deeply concerning
or deeply good for you she no longer
receives Christmas cards from Clinton's
and when she does our handlers open at
first before she Tulsi you know you know
what's funny you get Christmas cards
from her that'd be something I got a
Christmas card from vice president
Kamala Harris this last question that's
pretty cool it was it was you know like
the mass producer I was surprised
now if she wrote a personal note to you
what would that sound like
probably not full of Aloha
no Hearts I don't know nothing like that
it's great to finally be here are you
kidding me first of all you know I feel
like uh uh
we've spent a lot of time together
because I watched you over the years
you're a rock star you're amazing you're
you're one of the most uh uh necessary
voices that we have they get people who
are trying to reason and think for
themselves people say there's another
person like me out there you being one
of them and uh we're grateful for that
but today you know we got a lot of
issues to go through with you a lot of
things that's going on today Politics
the scientists yesterday the F-16
approval of the pilots Ukraine being
trained are you going to give it to him
or you're not going to give it to him
we'll cover that we'll talk about the
military-industrial complex we'll talk
about Durham report and a few other
things but before doing that question
for you if you and I were in 10th Grade
together who was Tulsi yabbard in high
school I'm curious
very shy uh introvert I'm the fourth of
five kids I have three older brothers
and a younger sister and uh by far
amongst the kids in our in our family
and and certainly even in my circles
um tomboy did martial arts love surfing
hiking Sports uh read voraciously
um
but very very shy and an introvert so if
you and I were in high school I probably
would not have spoken to you not because
of you very I I would like my mom would
send us to go to the grocery store and
buy you know some bread or whatever I
would I would not want to speak to the
clerk at the grocery store I'd make my
sister go she she is an extrovert
um
so when did it flip when were you like
you know what you know why am I so
nervous because I was shy as well we
need to flip out I I am I mean I'm you
know obviously I'm Still Still introvert
by nature but but the um so so you
mentioned I ran for the state house and
I was 21. uh it was very very the
hardest thing about that was going and
knocking on people's doors and and
starting those conversations to say
introduce myself and really asking for
the opportunity the privilege to serve
them every single door that I went to
was a huge uh cause of anxiety just
because of of that
um where it eventually turned actually
was uh I had served in the state house I
had deployed I come back I had served on
the Honolulu City councils when I was
running for congress that I just had to
take some time of introspection just
like
I I am pursuing this path of service
that I've committed my life to and yet
there are these self kind of created
hurdles of anxiety just because of that
that shyness and I I looked myself in
the mirror and I was like what's what's
your problem
well you got to figure this out and and
really just taking that time made me
realize that all of those fears and
insecurities the causes of that anxiety
were actually very selfish because I was
thinking like well
you know I don't want to sound stupid
what if they asked me a question I don't
know the answer to and I don't want to
bother them and and the common the
common word that came up as I was going
through this was was I and me I'm like
well that's a problem
especially as as you know I I had made
this decision to to pursue this path of
service and and so that was that was
where things changed where instead of
walking into a room something that would
cause anxiety and anyone who's an
introvert and shy you can probably
relate
was turned around when I realized like
stop thinking about yourself I'll see go
in this room and and take the
opportunity to connect with other people
to share Aloha with them to smile have a
nice conversation at a bare minimum and
once I shifted my focus on uh in that
way uh it changed everything I love it
because when when you when we watch you
on stage and uh Kamala goes after you
and then you go to back and forth when
Kamala and Biden were going job we're
going back and forth and you came in and
Bowman in the comments about Hillary and
what she said about you and everybody's
wondering how you're going to react and
your reaction was even stronger than the
way she did it and then you see this
person you're like this This Woman's got
Poise strength courage confidence is
willing to stand up for herself these
are not qualities of somebody that's
timid or shy so it's great that that
transition happened to you but the
question you read a lot I think to to to
your point on that
um
it it all I mean it is all rooted in a
place of of uh
intentionally every day uh choosing to
not put myself first service above self
and so as attacks are coming or what are
all of these other things that are
happening whether it was in the past or
just the stuff that we're dealing with
now on a daily basis you talked about
some of the things in your introduction
um for me recognizing it's not about me
so all this stuff is just like I'm not
in it for me uh the attacks can roll off
my shoulder and let me stay focused on
my mission is genuinely genuinely have
that mindset where it's about
service to others and helping the
country country first versus sort of
being an egomaniac I want to have power
I want to have notoriety unfortunately
not very many even though we hear these
words very often coming from politicians
the actions tell another story and this
is one of the most disheartening things
that I found when I was in Congress for
eight years was how many people in in
the house in the Senate their whole
identity is centered around this title
and so when when that is their identity
and I've seen this with people who've
left Congress and found themselves
feeling very almost worthless or
irrelevant because people aren't
inviting them to things anymore people
aren't asking them hey what's your
opinion on this and so for those who are
there you you can see how
they are willing to do whatever it takes
to keep that position or to climb to a
higher position because unfortunately
that's where they find their their self
is that one of the main reasons why
there there's no progress on term limits
in Congress just because the people
voting for it just don't want to leave
yeah I think there's that that's that's
one motivator
um it's also uh you know one of the
reasons why we see this endless uh
search and ambition for just more power
and more control because ultimately what
it comes down to it is about them rather
than saying hey we and this this applies
to both political parties as well their
well-being their means of existence
rather than like all right guys we have
very real problems how do we sit down
and figure out how to solve these
problems in a real and Lasting way and
and for those conversations uh we're
seeing some of them play out right now
or with the debt ceiling issue but we
see how these things just don't happen
but very often tell us a personal your
journey of going from hey first hear
military Hawaii then it's Bernie then
it's this then it's major then it's you
know all this Lieutenant Colonel now
Lieutenant Colonel really seriously they
gotta update your profile wow that's a
big deal
well I salute you man for being a
lieutenant what was your highest ranking
specialist I crushed it I did my two
years I'm out so you know there's
there's a real thing called the E4 Mafia
in the military oh he's very familiar
with that leader leaders at one time and
they cannot be underestimated shout out
to the E4 I'm happy I tell you on a
Leader's bulletin specialist party
better than any other title of the
military they know what to do okay so
going back to this the the
vulnerability of going through the
evolution of where you're at politically
and philosophically that's not easy to
do because in a way we have to publicly
put ourselves out there to either say I
was wrong about that belief at one point
of my life or to say listen I'm still of
the same belief you've changed and just
to affiliate myself with you I can't do
that anymore because this is ridiculous
and it's you've cornered me you're
putting me in a bad place but this is
what I'm going to be doing moving
forward what's the Journey of you
evolving with your personal philosophies
whether it's foreign as a military
person of course that's something you
have a lot of experience in
economically as you advance in life and
you're saying okay I'm noticing some of
these policies don't make sense yeah
socially you're seeing what's going on
with trans dilemma venue all these
things that you're being forced to kind
of have to agree with this what's that
evolution been for you politically
look I I think ultimately at its heart
it is about
um
being willing to learn I mean really
it's that simple you know the the the
mindset and world view and what I knew
when I enlisted you know when I enlisted
after uh uh because of 9 11 like so many
people and then going and deploying into
Iraq and having one thought about what
we were doing there and why and
you know what I later realized was was
uh you know a bag full of lies that was
sold to the American people that a lot
of us actually believed because we had
leaders in both parties who were telling
us hey this is true this is necessary
this is important for America it's
important for the world and then going
there in that situation and being
directly exposed to
um you know every day the
military-industrial complex you know
every in our camp we had one of the big
we were one of the bigger camps in Iraq
and uh KBR Halliburton was the
contractor every single place in our
camp from the porta-potties to the
little uh laundry Connex you know they
hired people from Nepal and the
Philippines to come and like hey you're
going to do laundry for the troops you
drop off your clothes they come back in
a plastic bag KBR Halliburton stamps on
everything on our food every single
thing that service that was provided in
our camp came through KBR Halliburton I
just talked to a friend of mine who is
on active duty is deployed to Poland
right now he said guess who is providing
all the services in our camp KBR
Halliburton we started making friends
with some of the people from the
Philippines who were there and like hey
how much you getting paid how often are
you able to go home and visit your
family in the Philippines very very very
little pay knowing they're charging the
US government the military astronomical
amounts of money to to provide these
services so just one example of many of
the exploitation that occurs especially
during times of War but also during
times of peace from the
military-industrial complex who's making
all the money who is being exploited and
and at what cost so you know
experiencing that serving in a medical
unit where every day I was confronted
with the High human cost of War
though our brothers and sisters who who
paid the price either through injury or
making that ultimate sacrifice these
experiences hugely impacted me and and
caused me to go deeper to want to learn
more about the foreign policy decisions
that our country was making learning
more over time about the unipart the
unit party that is the war machine in
Washington and the forces that be so
that's one example of many but but uh
you know I guess I guess intentionally
having the humility to understand and
know that I don't know everything and to
continue to learn whether it's on
foreign policy or domestic policy uh and
and keeping at the Forefront what's most
important is not me stand here and
saying I'm right at all what's most
important is is trying to find the right
answer in that mission of serving the
American people in the interests of our
country but I think most reasonable
Americans are you so most people are
going through that process as well but
they they're cornered at feeling guilty
if they're not loyal to a certain
philosophy or losing friends or not
being invited to parties or what are
people going to say if I post this if I
post that so Bernie Sanders and Joe
Biden you know you endorse both of these
guys at one point I like Bernie as a
person I actually believe Bernie more
than I believe almost every one of the
guys on the left when I say I believe
what his philosophies are I think it's
sincere I don't think he's of course
I'll call him out on the taxes
millionaires now millionaires and
billionaires the moment he became a
millionaire of billionaires and
billionaires you know so it's like you
know as long as you're not that so
there's a little bit of evolution
contradiction and evolution there for
him as well yes so for you what what
appealed to you with Bernie and then
what was the situation with Joe yeah
President Biden in 2020
uh so as you mentioned I was vice chair
of the DNC as we were headed into that
2016 election uh it was starting to
shape up to be a direct
um uh kind of Face-Off between Bernie
Sanders and Hillary Clinton Bernie
obviously shocked everybody with the the
massive momentum and Grassroots support
that he built the establishment
Washington believing I mean Hillary she
obviously is the establishment embodies
The Establishment but they didn't
believe that the power of the people
could harness that energy to create a
real competition but it happened
um I had every intention of of remaining
as Vice chair of the DNC and trying to
do my best as a neutral officer to
ensure that
um as we went through the primary
process that it would be fair and truly
neutral which is the rule actually the
rules of the party uh very quickly under
Debbie Wasserman Schultz who's the chair
of the party at the time
I started to see that was not the case
at all you know she was making
unilateral decisions uh not only without
consulting us as officers of the DNC but
actually we would find out about her
decisions oftentimes uh when they were
released to the media or on social media
but seeing very blatantly how she was
tilting the scales to favor Hillary
Clinton and try to handicap Bernie
Sanders tried to limit his exposure to
voters through the debate process
implementing a rule that said hey any
candidate that participates in a debate
that is not sanctioned by the DNC will
be banned from participating in all
future DNC debates how can they do that
though how can she makes the rules
unilaterally we were kind of talking
about that last night and your name came
up last night we're at the Cigar Lounge
talking what are what are the
disadvantages now that you've been part
of it because you you were a star among
stars you know you became a superstar
where there was a time you we talked
about you every day on what you were
doing I'm talking politically when a new
athlete comes out in the MBA you're a
footballer look at this Superstar this
guy's amazing right what they're doing
that was you but then the conversation
came about you know she's not defending
the establishment and you need the
establishment to make it now that you've
been through this and you've been in
that world whether from the media side
individually on the stage you know
establishment going up against the Biden
going up against all these other guys
how much uh uh how much does a candidate
need the backing of the establishment to
stand a chance of winning and to say you
do but if you were to go and go up
against the establishment these are the
three things you need to stand a chance
to win what would you say to that I I
have never had the establishments
backing not when I ran for State office
or uh city council or when I ran for
congress I was never the obvious choice
from a party you're an establishment
standpoint and frankly even had some
people in the Hawaii Democratic party
who were actively opposing my my
candidacy and so I was shocked when a
couple of weeks after I was sworn and as
a member of Congress I got a call saying
do you want to be Vice chair of the DNC
like I had no insight into the
establishment organizations and
literally my response was I don't know
what is a vice chair of the DNC do what
are you really asking of me but said yes
because okay well here's an opportunity
to try to to bring about some reforms
that would actually ensure the
Democratic party is truly Democratic and
listening and connected to the people
and perhaps a little too idealistic as I
went through that but really my eyes
being opened into the fact that well
this party is actually has become a
party of Elites uh serving the interests
of the elites and not the interests of
the people who they are supposed to be
whose cause they are supposed to be
championing and so so back back to your
question I I resigned as Vice sure the
DNC specifically because of what was
going on in that 2016 primary and and
specifically related to foreign policy
Bernie and I don't agree on every issue
but on foreign policy we had a situation
in 2016 where Hillary Clinton was being
touted as excuse me the most qualified
candidate ever to run for president in
the history of our country
all of the talking heads on television
use that line almost every single day
and yet they did not talk about
what her record actually was
the the stream of Destruction and War
and toppled regimes and failed States
and dead bodies that she left in her
wake they refused to have her even
answer uh you know basic questions about
that record not in debate stages not in
interviews and frankly Bernie Sanders
wasn't even bringing it up that much
when in fact that was
one of the biggest differences I mean he
has a a largely non-interventionist
leaning foreign policy I resigned as
Vice to the DNC uh and endorsed him
specifically on foreign policy to
maximize whatever platform I could uh
have to shine a light on that contrast
on that difference and uh and expose
Hillary's foreign policy record and hold
her accountable
um uh to it
about can you can you be successful in
politics without the establishment
support yes absolutely uh is it the
easiest path is it the shortest path no
but if your interest is in uh remaining
committed to
the people of this country or the people
of your constituency or of your District
that's where my focus has always been uh
and unfortunately we are living in a
time where the establishment interest is
not the interests of the people so if
you want to go play The Insider politics
game The Establishment game uh it you'll
you'll go you'll go places it comes at a
very very high cost uh going up against
them
it it even comes at a high cost
of personal compromise and a compromise
of Integrity if you choose to play that
game and yes going up and challenging
them is not just challenging the DNC or
the Democratic party right it is also
challenging all of their Partners in the
mainstream corporate media challenging
uh elements of the National Security
State that they are weaponizing for
their own interests challenging their
friends and partners in big Tech and
social media who are very willing to do
their bidding so it is this whole kind
of cabal of elitism that benefits off of
having people in positions of power that
they can control and that's where as you
said people were talking about me a lot
at one point but once they realize okay
she's not falling for the glitter and
things that were dangling in front of
her and she thinks for herself and uh it
it speaks her own mind uh that's where
that's where the tables kind of started
to turn and you know I stopped getting
invited to the the parties and the stuff
that I know
what are these
he says it comes at a cost yeah being
purchased by The Establishment what does
that mean exactly like in terms of
yeah I've seen it in friends of mine
people who uh
who came in uh with the best of
intentions and maybe throughout still
maintain the best of intentions and
didn't really realize you know in in the
in the best sense of the word didn't
realize how okay well I'll just do this
in order to get this done or I'll just
do that and I'll compromise this or that
or whatever
um and and not really realize that they
were losing themselves in the process
and I've also I also know those who are
very blatant about it like yeah I will
in a very calculating way do anything
that is required in order to get myself
to this position or this title or or
hold this this amount they're going to
hold you hostage exactly and I've seen
that I've seen it on the house floor
during votes people being chased down
now if you if you if you do that if you
play that game they've got leverage over
you vote for this or else if you don't
support us we're gonna take away this
money it's a threatening absolutely okay
absolutely so so let's but let's stay on
this so for example the the prop we had
Whitney Webb here uh yesterday or two
days or three days or something like
that and Whitney web here and she wrote
a couple books going up against you know
Epstein and a bunch of different lacks
and all these guys she's very good at
what she does
and one of the questions I asked her
which has prompted a lot of discussion
the last couple days is
so all these establishments okay who is
establishment like right now if we were
to say who's the chairman of the board
of the establishment party of course
it's not a party who would you say is
the chairman of the board at the time
Hillary Clinton okay you put her ahead
of Obama oh yeah oh so she is still
ahead of Obama for establishment who do
you put on the board like if you look at
who who was who was uh you know even
though they were up against each other
in 2008 I mean you look at the people
who populated the Obama Administration
Hillary Clinton being Secretary of State
and you look at the people who are
populating the Biden Administration
who's his National Security Council
director Jake Sullivan who is Hillary
Clinton's right hand guy
got it so you put her so you don't you
don't subscribe to this mindset that
Obama's really on this third term and
he's running the country that's not
where you're at I think he is I think he
is playing a very impactful role but uh
Hillary Clinton uh spent decades still
building that Clinton machine that is
still very much you think she still
plays a role in the Biden Administration
yes so here's the question yes so here's
a question here's a question so if
that's the case to go up
is the goal in order for America to be
free
to go up against establishment expose
them replace them with people that are
Statesmen and hold them accountable
would you say that should be one of
American voters top goals it is the
essential objective we're on the same
page so now he this course can I add one
little thing of course sure it is
because you look at um I talked a little
bit about this in my talk yesterday
about when you look at the words that
the founders used in our founding
documents We the People a self-governed
nation we are the ones who have the
ability to make this change it feels
hopeless at times because of how much
money and power and all these machines
that are that exist to maintain that
status quo of power but ultimately at
The Ballot Box we are the ones who have
the power to make the kind of change
you're talking about and hold these
elected leaders accountable and they
need to be people of Courage who have
the backbone and the strength
to completely clean out the
administrative state
the bureaucrats who have their own
agenda and who are very willing to
either undermine the direction and
interests of the people that we elect
the president United States uh and and
uh continue to thrive off of this
revolving this corrupt revolving door uh
that exists between special interests
and those who are unelected uh yet who
are making the kinds of changes through
rules and regulations that should be
done legislatively Title IX is one
example of this perfect we're going the
right direction we're on the same page
there I agree with you but I think you
know the challenge then becomes the
following if you look at all the
establishment and as well as some of
these institutions that have made our
lives horrible since November of you
know
1963 till today let's go 63 till today
November 22nd assassination John F
Kennedy so I'm purely going November 1st
till today you can add FBI CIA you can
put in there doj military industrial
complex you can you know Whitney talked
about the big Tech firms she put IBM but
she put all the social media companies
she put pritzker the the folks from Big
Pharma lobbyists you said fed right we
went through all the in the names Biden
you know there were names from both
sides left and to right okay
when you think about who in the last 60
years that has had the weight to go up
against these guys you have to look at
who was hated the most by those
institutions and organizations and
establishment Kennedy was hated by those
guys because they were on their way to
want to undermine them and another guy
named Donald was right so obviously on
two opposite sides one guy was a second
amendment guy in 1963 John F Kennedy
they were NRA Card members today I'm not
sure he would have been a Democrat today
maybe he would have been a Libertarian
independent possibly a center right type
of a position he would have been today
but to go up against these guys that a
lot of people think they're evil okay
the the when you look at you know we'll
go into this as well with the whole esgd
ICI stuff we'll go into that afterwards
but
the person to go up against the
establishment
how does the average voter be able to
tell the difference on who that
candidate is because whoever has the
guts and the ability and the willingness
and as a True Believer to do that
every institution is going to pin him as
a bad guy or bad girl they're not going
to Market this person as a good
candidate they're going to have to do
whatever they can to do character
assassination so how does the voter
see between that
massive character assassination and
saying but I think this is the guy or
this is the guy that can do the job how
do we differentiate between the two
people's trust in the mainstream media
has radic radically radically been uh
reduced over time I I think it's that
it's probably at a historic low at this
point uh people's trust in our public
institutions has continued to drop why
because we have been lied to and cheated
and evidence has been shown how corrupt
these entities have unfortunately become
so I think how do we know I think the
first question is if you have uh you
know off in the mainstream media they
end up parroting all of the same talking
points when they're saying the very same
thing about someone like oh this is the
best person who's ever come along they
are going to come and save the country
me I'd be like I don't know I'm gonna
dig deeper into that person this seems
kind of suspicious and in my case you
know I've they pair at the same talking
points and accusations and baseless
smears against me I have heard from
people who are saying hey I've heard
them saying all this stuff about you
doesn't seem right I want to learn more
so I think I think identifying the
messenger uh and uh being able to see
through that facade of lies or it's not
a facade of Lies they are actually lies
but seeing through that facade uh to
recognize the truth or at least uh the
need to dig deeper to learn more I think
is is where uh
we're moving in that direction and I
think we're also seeing evidence of this
with people migrating more towards New
Media podcasts like your shows like
yours and others who you know where they
can actually Gain real information and
they know they're not being fed like a
sound bite by sound bite um you know
sheet of Lies what do you think about
Trump or DeSantis as a candidate
uh tell me more what do you mean I mean
okay so let's just say you are somebody
that
um
you're the Sorrows of the right there
isn't one but let's just say you're the
Sorrows of the right
the source of the left he is helping
these guys out in ways that if you're on
the left you have to send this guy a
Valentine's Day card a it doesn't matter
Memorial Day card he's never served but
you got to tell him thank you for your
service if you're a Democrat he's that
guy right
uh on the right there's not really one
there you know they think they are but
they're not really there they claim they
want to make the investment they're not
going to cut the check and buy Vice and
buy Time Magazine and buy New York Times
or L.A times on to buy Forbes it was
just on sale somebody else they're just
not willing to put the money there they
kind of want to go live in Palm Beach
have a nice place and be left alone and
just kind of go have drinks and do
whatever they want to do it's
unfortunate because they're not Fighters
once they make their money the Dems are
more Fighters and True Believers a lot
of times
Republican billionaires talk more than
they actually do the fighting so but
let's just say you are that person okay
and you're a sinner right person with a
lot of money and you have the ability to
get behind a candidate that's willing to
fight against the establishment where
would you put Trump to santis or even
others as a qualified candidate to go up
against this task
it's going to be an ugly one who would
you say is the most qualified to do that
job
um
I don't know is is honest answer
um I I don't know enough about all the
different people who are running uh
Trump has obviously shown he has taken
on both you know all of all of the
establishments you know obviously the
Democrats the Republican Party the media
and I think that's one reason why a lot
of people are drawn to him is is
um he says what a lot of people are
thinking in some ways even if it's not
nice to hear uh but is willing to to
kind of take on these these machines
that have been perceived to be too
powerful uh to take on and I think I
think Ron DeSantis has done that in some
ways but
um I I think it remains it remains to be
seen I think that's the beauty of this
this election process is that voters
will have the time and the opportunity
as they should both for republicans and
Democrats and and with the dnc's
decision to uh not allow Democratic
voters to have that opportunity is truly
offensive and disrespectful uh to voters
I saw what you tweeted yesterday about
the whole with RFK well let me but what
are we talking about out here against
Mojo is like but let's we said the same
thing in 2015 yeah but he was a
candidate and this is a different story
because it's you know Joe Biden's
ticking and he gets to choose and decide
and there's no way exactly so so I mean
this the the message that comes through
there with with Simone Sanders saying
that but she used to be Bernie Sanders
communications director back during the
2016 campaign and the fact that she said
I think the beginning that she said I'm
trying to keep myself from laughing
at Joe's question about why you know why
aren't there going to be debates or are
there going to be debates like they
really think it's a joke and that's what
they think this is Joe Scarborough Joe
Scarborough Joe Scarborough asking the
question
who was he asking he was asking you can
just play the clip the Democratic side
Bobby Kennedy Jr
doing well he's at 19
hasn't really gotten that that much out
there I mean it's and I'm starting to
hear more and more talk about him are we
going to actually have a challenge here
I'm trying not to laugh Joe there's not
going to can I just
stop you for a second
because there was going to be a
Republican primary but I really think
that uh the mealy mouth Democrats as I
like to call them and some of my
Progressive friends who would like to
live in a fantasy land they need to come
back to reality and the reality is this
the sitting president of the United
States of America is a Democrat a
Democrat that would like to run for
re-election so much so that he has
declared a re-election campaign in that
case the Democratic National Committee
will not facilitate a primary process
there will be no debate stage for Bobby
Kennedy Marine Wood Marianne Williamson
or anyone else so we're going to have
another Bobby Kennedy and an empty chair
in the debate right there will be no
baby
committee administers the debates and
they're not going to set up a primary
process for debates too for someone to
challenge the head of the democratic
party so here's what I hope Bobby
Kennedy does is is goes to you guys goes
to Joe Rogan goes to multiple people who
have platforms and say will you host a
debate invite Joe Biden invite Marianne
Williamson and let him not show up
they're they're her the keywords there
she says they have to come to reality
and what is the reality that the DNC
believes that they are the Arbiters of
democracy
and they will decide if there's no
debates then there will be no debates
well guess what there's a whole country
out here that's actually interested the
fact that Bobby Kennedy is what I think
he's north of 20 now he's he hasn't even
been in a campaign for more a month at
this point the fact that Joe Biden has
such low approval they're they're less
than 30 percent of Democrats people want
him to run and yet they're saying there
will be no debate because of the DNC
there's a lot of folks out there who
would like to hear more and learn more
and I hope that that Bobby Kennedy and
uh creates that opportunity and invites
Joe Biden to show up I think that's a
brilliant idea I think we might want to
implement that strategy Pat question for
you Tulsi I mean I think it's disgusting
that they're just kind of hiding Joe
Biden in a basement it's almost sort of
like a Weekend at Bernie's type of thing
they're just going to string them out
there but at the same time if you look
at the Republican primary Trump has in
so many words said that he probably
won't even show up to the RNC debates do
you think Trump
you know Trump just did this CNN Town
Hall that I don't know that DeSantis
would agree to do a CNN I don't know
maybe he would maybe he wouldn't but uh
for every debate that I've seen Trump
has done very well
so I don't I don't know but no I mean I
think I think that
um
I think that he would probably do well
and I think the voters uh would
appreciate being able to have candidates
there on the stage obviously it's up to
him it'll make a decision but
um I think it would send a strong
statement is it fair to say
you know 2016 you were Bernie 2020 Biden
you endorse Biden if it were Trump Biden
again in 2024 How likely is it that you
would vote for Trump this time around
I will not be supporting Joe Biden under
any circumstances you know that what
happened in 2016 or 2020 rather at that
point was
um you know the race on the Democratic
primary side had had virtually been
decided and uh I've known Joe Biden for
a long time and I felt uh that he the
The Joe Biden I knew was a good-hearted
man who had the best of intentions uh
for the country and so I had hoped that
he would listen to his better angels and
provide the kind of leadership uh that
our country needed unfortunately he has
proven
um
that to be wrong I mean that that that
uh that that hope unfortunately never
never came about and and I think uh
obviously he is the president he is
responsible he is accountable the people
he has surrounded himself with uh are uh
more divisive uh more destructive of
pushed us to the brink of World War III
and nuclear war from a domestic policy
and a foreign policy standpoint have
been uh
have had a destructive effect on our
country that I'm concerned if they were
to continue and be re-elected uh it
would take us to a place that perhaps
you could not come back from number one
and number two before long we would we
would have a president Kamala Harris as
commander-in-chief which which I and
others who wear the uniform find to be
uh
scary beyond belief what would a Kamala
Harris Administration look like if she's
you know if Joe Biden is incapable of
leading at some point you know that's a
concern or if she's actually even
elected Dooley uh what do you think that
Administration she has first of all from
from again the most important
responsibility that the president has is
to serve as commander-in-chief that is
the sole job that only the president has
that Congress does not weigh in on you
know uh presidential candidates talk a
lot about education and immigration all
these other policies where you can't get
anything done unless you work with
Congress to get them to pass legislation
the foreign policy decisions the
commander-in-chief makes are decisions
that that person alone makes Kamala
Harris is
completely uh unqualified and lacks not
only the knowledge and experience but
the temperament to serve in that
position and what's dangerous about that
is number one she will be manipulated by
the military-industrial complex by
people who have a lot of stars on their
shoulders from the Pentagon who uh would
like to see us continue to be in a state
of War for a number of reasons rather
than to pursue peace and diplomacy and
she would as we've seen with others in
the past she would feel as though she
needs to project strength
it's the most dangerous thing to have a
weak person feel like they need to
project strength and have the US
military at their fingertips to do that
if you could only vote for Joe Biden or
Kamala Harris who would have your vote
oh my gosh that's not a tough one I
guess no I'm not that's like a
ridiculous hypothesis well I mean it's
not that ridiculous we're kind of in
that world right
that's not the question though you asked
the right question a minute ago uh
between the two and she gave the answer
that she won't be voting for Biden so
which means it's anything but a Biden
Kamala because her concern is Kamala and
many people are on the same page with
that comologist doesn't give Vibes of a
VP let alone a you know a command or
achieve that's a that's a scary sight
for her to sit there negotiating with
Putin or G yeah oh my God I mean that's
the first place I go to I go sit there
and say who are the most top 10 biggest
power players or leaders in the world
who do you want sitting there
negotiating on your behalf without you
being there with cameras off yeah I do
not want her negotiating on my behalf I
just don't I'll just add one thing to
what you said I think it's important I I
don't believe it's anybody but Joe Biden
I I don't I don't take that approach to
anyone because we have some Republicans
who uh hold the exact same foreign
policies as a Hillary Clinton or a Joe
Biden and so I think that's where it's
important for us as we go through this
process to be able to look at each
candidate and not just go off of like
okay Republican good Democrat bad
Democrat good Republican bad because
again we look at the war machine we look
at permanent Washington we see people
who may look a little different may come
from different parties May say slightly
different things but at their core their
message they will perpetuate the same
corrupt status quo so here's a question
for you
um I like to play the game I'm with Shaq
and I ask Shaq as a shack starting
lineup you got first draft pick I got
second number one who do you pick I got
Michael I got this I got that I got this
and we're putting a team together to see
who wins right draft pick
give me your top three draft picks
on presidential candidates that are the
most qualified to fight against the
establishment and have a fighting chance
of winning or maybe making progress
purely draft pick who would some of
those names be for you
I think it's too soon to tell that's not
too sure I think you're dodging the
question a little bit I think a little
bit but but
I am mostly because then somebody's
going to say well I'm endorsing
candidates
then forget about forget about top three
don't rank them okay give names and you
don't have to give them an order okay
you know what I'm saying and I'm being
and I'm being serious
I'm not looking for an endorsement I
know you're not but that's how these
things will be interpreted but but but
if you look at it right now like okay
let's just we were with DeSantis a week
ago at the governor's mansion 10 15 of
us spend five hours together with you
know himself Casey you know others and
watching to see how he is behind closed
doors and you know what messaging and
all this stuff is being given we've
already publicly announced we'll do a
fundraiser at the house for uh for Biden
for Trump for DeSantis come do a
fundraiser we'll bring top 20 of the
biggest in
we would gladly bring Bobby into Bobby
we're talking right now about doing a
podcast with him I think June 28th we're
doing a live uh podcast with a couple
hundred people with vivec I would love
to get a Marianne Williamson to maybe
debate him and see what that setting
will look like because if they're not
gonna we're gonna get him 10 20 50
million eyeballs we'll get the eyeballs
so this is not a time for these guys to
play Big Shot thinking those guys are
not going to get the eyeballs anymore
but I'm sincerely asking somebody that I
believe you you love America I firmly
believe you love America and I firmly
believe a lot of people
relate to you and I know the the the
um uh I've been around business for 20
some years I know how to dodge questions
professionally because you have to do
that when you're negotiating Etc et
cetera I'm not asking I'm not trying to
Corner you just give me
names and why like I think this per like
for example RFK here's why the santis
here's what whoever it would be what was
some of those names here's what I'll
tell you because you know Rhonda Santos
and I served together in Congress but
but to be quite honest I don't know him
very well so what I know of him is what
I have seen mostly publicly uh but I
haven't had a chance to to sit in the
room as you have to actually really get
to know him both as a person but also
really to get into some of the more
National issues to include foreign
policy that would inform my ability to
answer your question what I will say is
that people like Nikki Haley uh Mike
Pence uh Mike Pompeo
um
and Chris Christie we're seeing Governor
ASA Hutchinson
they are all part of the uh permanent
establishment
uh machine uh whose foreign policy would
be very very uh
if not exactly the same mostly the same
as a Hillary Clinton Warhawk uh so those
those are the kinds of things that I I
have picked up on that I'm looking for
as these other candidates
um are out there and they're talking
about their positions on issues and and
unfortunately as is always the case I
mean you know
even though being commander-in-chief is
the president's most important and
foremost responsibility uh
the focus on what kinds of decisions
they would make as commander-in-chief
don't often come up in debates or in
forums and and a lot of these
presidential candidates don't don't
choose to talk about them so
um I'm hoping as you guys have your
forums that that's something and I that
you would that you would help shine a
light on because it is it is literally a
matter of life and death to know what
are the kinds of decisions these people
would make are they going to put us
closer to nuclear war with other
nuclear-armed countries or not because
that that the future of humanity is on
the line Tulsi I totally respect the
fact that if you haven't you know you're
not prepared to make any endorsements
and if you've never really sat down with
DeSantis and you know it's kind of hard
to acknowledge all that but at the same
time in 2020 you did share the stage
with a host of Democrats Bernie Biden
Amy Klobuchar Elizabeth Warren Andrew
Yang he's been on the platform before
Cory Booker Marianne Williamson Beto the
list goes on uh of all those names who
do you think you most closely align with
or would be a good leader how about that
I mean these are people you know sure uh
who did you get along with even on a
personal level who do you think would be
a good leader of that group
my answer today would probably be
different than it was back then largely
because with everything that we've gone
through since 20 like I feel like we've
almost lived a lifetime from 2020 until
now in 2012. it was this little thing
called code yeah
the the little thing called covid uh
frankly the the the proxy war with
Russia via Ukraine I mean a lot of
people's uh lack of Courage
unfortunately has been exposed
um you know the fact that not a single
Democrat not a single Democrat uh has
voted against you know remember that
first 40 billion round of funding to go
uh that kind of brought in the United
States involvement in this war against
Russia not a single Democrat voted
against it I think there were between
the House and Senate something like 60
or 70 Republicans uh who voted against
but not a single Democrat had the
courage to even just say let's not rush
into this let's actually think about
what are the second third fourth order
of consequences that could occur once we
bring ourselves into this what happens
when we start to turn on the tap at what
point do we turn it off
the the progressive caucus in I think it
was November of last year if you
remember they sent this 30 members of
Congress sent a letter to Joe Biden
saying
please exercise diplomacy to negotiate
an end to this war because if it goes on
it will not only continue to create more
suffering and death for the people of
Ukraine but it increases the risk of
nuclear war it will increase
um the the negative impacts on our
economy on inflation on hunger and all
of these things that are that are facts
that are very real costs of this war
they sent the letter one day within 24
hours they retracted it
they retracted it it was some [__]
excuse like oh a staffer sent out a
letter uh without our approval which is
nonsense absolute nonsense we know what
happened they sent out a letter saying
how they actually felt and they got they
they they they got the hammer laid down
on them and unfortunately didn't have
the courage to say no
this is bigger than Party politics we as
Democrats they as democrats should have
the courage to call out your own
president and I would say the same thing
for Republicans so you know it is I have
been really disappointed on a foreign
policy perspective but also with you
know
men going into girls locker rooms and
exposing themselves all and this being
okay in the name of this trans ideology
and and and pervasive acceptance of
something that that is just
um dangerous and and fantasy this gender
ideology title like all of these things
that are so obvious in common sense that
most people see
they're they're I can't think of a
single elected Democrat in the house or
the Senate a lot of the names that
you've mentioned who've stood up and
just said you know what the kid says
right hey guys the emperor has no
clothes on let's just all admit that
it's not happening and it's and it's
really unfortunate and it's not
reflective of where I believe most
Democrats are in the country so none of
those names no one that you shared a
stage with
you would look back and be like that
person is actually qualified that person
is good they've all been dismissed from
class
okay so to to finalize this before we
move off this topic uh I got seven more
questions for you on this topic
no let me let me let me ask this so so
so again your your voice whether you
know it or not I'm sure you know it
carries weight and people
uh watch to see what you have to say
and so think about it from this
standpoint the audience is watching this
is going to get a few million views say
total 40 million views short clips Tick
Tock Instagram people watch you
who should they
study more closely and do the research
you did if you were to say I think like
you just made a comment and you said hey
I've never spent time with the
scientists and by the way
you're not the only person that's ever
said that a lot of people have said that
that they haven't spent a lot of time
with DeSantis so he's not the guy that
wants to be in the group setting like
when you came in here you and I have
never met each other before but we
greeted each other with a hug hey how
you doing you have that feeling of
warmth and conversation great you know
this is somebody that's likable Charmed
charismatic people never really said
that about him they've said he's sharp
he's a doer he's an executive all this
stuff but who is worthy of the American
people on their own going and
investigating and watching closely what
would you say
um I think every every one of these
candidates have taken that's taken the
step to run so you know Tim Scott is
somebody I know I like him a lot he's a
great person
um I'm interested in learning more about
what what his positions are on specific
issues vivec same thing he and I have
had a few conversations great
conversations I like a lot of the things
that he's saying also have a lot of
questions I think going you know
obviously you know Trump is more well
known he's got a record uh DeSantis has
a record here as governor of the state
but also his uh record uh you know
before that uh in Congress I think I
think it is it is very important this
election the the the importance of this
election can't be overstated and so
um I don't I think it I think you know
as Bobby Kennedy is going people are
getting to know him better
though they do say that the most
important question but I think this one
actually is and I've never seen it it is
no but I I let me tell you why I think
this one actually is I'll tell you why I
think this one actually is and I'm gonna
come back to my question on the last one
before I wrap up seven more hey no it's
only one question and I hope she gives
this one because I'm I need your counsel
I need your help sincerely I need your
help here's here's why I think this one
is and I think this is the problem uh
you know the difference between a
democracy and a republic there's a big
difference a republic the individual is
protected from the majority it's very
important where the individual is
protected from the majority right now
you know
in every Community there's issues that
goes on in some communities hey you know
HOA is this much money for every person
that lives in this community but it's
not fair the people that own more land
should pay bigger HOA than we're paying
that's kind of like one of the things
that's going on right now okay great you
want to do that yes you should pay three
times because you want the biggest lot
and you have the most land here no
problem then I should also have the
equivalent amount of votes for the
amount of lots I'm paying for so I
should get three votes you should get
one vote let's talk about that I'm okay
with that I got three votes your vote is
one dude no no no no we didn't say that
no [__] you didn't say that because now
you know you can't bully the individuals
so I'm an individual I want to be
protected I think this next one is very
important because
if they flip Texas
and that flips you know you're talking
about having a Democratic president for
the next 20 years and if the selection
thing doesn't go into the blockchain
technology where you and I can vote from
home and you simply do a camera like
this whatever the same we do with your
phone and you show your ID this is me
you say a couple things they recorded
they know it's you then you put your
name great this person voted you don't
even have to get off your you know the
couch to go there and that's a real vote
we have that ability to push for voting
to become real I think if we don't do it
this time around this is going to change
a lot of things but I'm going to go to
the last question for you so help me
with this
help me help America so if I'm sitting
with uh vivec I'll give you four names
vivec DeSantis president Trump and let's
put in uh uh RFK those four names give
me one question I should ask all of
those for an individual could be
different so I would ask Vivek this
question I would ask Trump this question
I would ask the centers this question
and I would ask RFK this question what
would the number one question be that
you'd want me to ask on behalf of the
American people of these four folks
it would be
what is the first thing that you will do
okay to
I'm taking notes
to de-escalate tensions with
nuclear-armed powers
in the world
and prevent the likelihood of nuclear
war we are on the brink we are that's a
fact
ask them directly what steps will you
take
that's the answer that I'm most
interested in hearing from them I love
it thank you for that we can get off
this topic this was very helpful now
let's go into that topic about disco
de-escalating War
so a military-industrial complex you
know we hear about this all the time can
you play this clip for me from uh this
gentleman that I'm starting to really
like I'm a big fan of what India is
doing and what India is capable of doing
of course they're part of bricks but I'm
watching them very closely to see what I
think they're going to be a very very
important uh force to be reckoned with
the next 20 30 40 years Dr subramanian
uh Josh Shankar okay who is an Indian
Diplomat and politician serving as the
minister yeah he's a beast he is their
Secretary of State their apartment
that's right he's I think the second
since uh and he's become the second ever
Diplomat to be appointed as external
affairs minister very sharp I like what
he says in this question someone's
asking him a question about Ukraine so
I'll kind of preface what the question
was and you'll hear his response I'm
sure you've seen this where it's like
hey so we're noticing everybody around
the world is supporting Ukraine but you
guys are not why are you not and this is
his answer go ahead Rob to grow out of
the mindset no refresh because you skip
the first second yeah
oh you got to refresh at the same time
so he says Europe has to grow out of
this mindset to grow out of the mindset
that Europe's problems are the world's
problems
but the world's problems are not
Europe's problems the world cannot be
that eurocentric as it used to be in the
past
I'm going to go to the the sit on you
and Tucker hat this was one of the ones
few months ago a couple months ago where
he's talking about I was never a trump
guy you know I've seen of course I'm
like what is this guy talking about he's
out of his mind and I wonder he asked
the question and says who funds NATO I'm
like who gives a [__] about who funds
NATO you remember this exchange with
them and he said then I started looking
I said yo why are we doing this much
money why are we putting so much more he
says the more and more I saw him asking
this question I'm like okay these are
very very good questions so why do you
think for the longest time uh Europe has
gotten away with everybody having to
support them but when it comes down to
them having to pay the bill they're like
no it's kind of like a friend you go to
a restaurant with and yeah yeah I'll do
another old-fashioned Palace to another
old-fashioned and when it comes on for
the build they get up and go to the
bathroom Europe seems to be doing that
and the other guy gets the bill and the
guy that gets the bill is U.S
the mindset of the military-industrial
complex with what's happened with
Ukraine and yesterday bro uh Joe Biden
talking about the fact he was asked
about will we give them F-16 fighter
jets and Biden says uh not today will
you one day give I can't answer that
question but I think we ought to start
training and the U.S official said we
will not uh you know turn away from any
other country who wants to support them
with F-16 essentially what they're
saying is we went from money to tanks to
this to now we're probably going to give
him some f-16s so why is your concern so
uh high or a lot of people why are so
many people concerned about
military-industrial complex why should
that be a top priority for them as a
concern
there's a number of reasons why let's
start with the most important that we're
talking about uh that that as we sit
here today we we are on the brink of
nuclear war
that should be concerning to everyone it
should be even more concerning that we
have people in positions of consequence
and power and influence influence both
those who hold public office in in the
highest offices of the land as well as
those who
um
who don't but who are are just as
influential talking about the prospects
of nuclear war as though it is just like
any other kind of War talking about the
fact that Putin and and his uh
government has changed their policies to
make it so that they can deploy nuclear
weapons whether they be tactical nuclear
weapons or strategic nuclear weapons if
they feel that they are facing an
existential threat specifically omitting
the words an existential threat because
of a nuclear threat or nuclear weapons
so whatever they deem
for any reason to be an existential
threat will give them the authority to
be able to uh deploy these nuclear
weapons the fact that we have these
pundits these Talking Heads these
government officials discussing the
prospects of nuclear war as though it is
something that can be won
is
shocking
and extremely dangerous
Ronald Reagan had the most famous and
most important statement
after he negotiated some of these
non-nuclear proliferation treaties
telling us very clearly a nuclear war
can never be won and should never be
fought period things have only gotten or
things haven't gotten better since then
we have more nuclear weapons they have
they have become more sophisticated uh a
nuclear weapon would kick off nuclear
war that would destroy uh all of all of
humanity uh the military-industrial
complex plays a major role in continuing
to keep us in some state of War why and
they some of them have even said it
publicly when we are at War business is
good
what is the cost the cost comes out of
our pockets our our bank accounts the
American people the taxpayers we are
paying for it uh where those dollars
could be and should be dedicated towards
actually serving very real needs of
people that we have right here at home
uh the military-industrial complex uh
profits when you see a NATO expansion
that because who are who are the uh the
people that these NATO countries are
buying weapons from they're buying the
weapons from our military industrial
complex when you look at the U.S footing
the bill for NATO number one we should
be able to ask questions like why does
NATO exist why are we the ones who are
predominantly funding NATO well with the
predominantly of funding of NATO comes
the very same leverage we were talking
about earlier getting these European
countries to act not necessarily in
their own interest but in the interest
of those in power in the United States
is done oftentimes through the leverage
of money so when Trump is saying hey you
guys got to pay your own way pay the two
percent my gosh pay the two percent of
your GDP that the rules are common sense
uh many of them didn't want to but then
what comes with that and you saw
recently with um
I think it was macron's visit uh
overseas and to China largely saying the
same thing to the European countries hey
we need to stop being vassals of the
United States we need to make our own
decisions based on what's best for our
countries and what's based in the best
interests of Europe the criticism he got
for having the audacity to say hey we
should act in the interest of our own
countries
says everything that we need to know
about the power and the influence and
the money that goes behind these
decisions so there's an economic cost of
course to us and the American people in
our country and there's a the the the uh
the cost that comes to our safety our
security uh and our freedom and the
human costs of life exactly funding all
these wars I mean exactly money's
important I get it but not millions and
millions of lives that are lost such a
great Point you're making you know it's
funny Rob if you can find that one clip
that I ask you to pull up you know the
one where uh the lady says how do you
feel about the half a million you know
which one I'm talking about you know
this one yeah all right yeah so this
clip can't be played enough times if you
can play this real quick
we have heard that a half a million
children have died I mean that's more
children than died when in Hiroshima and
and
you know is the price worth it
I think this is a very hard choice but
the price we think the price is worth
price is worth it okay so and she is
somebody who throughout her life
all the way to the end was lauded and
worshiped by democrats in the Democratic
party
under Clinton exactly this is this is a
while back I don't know what this
timeline the interview is Rob if you
can't find it I'm 98 or 1990 yeah
something like that but you know so you
know how we're kids and we're like uh uh
we all think we're tough guys right
what'd you say I'm gonna kick your ass
96. I'm gonna kick your ass and you're
like okay maybe you gotta punch in and
everybody breaks it you know that's
right okay fine no problem man that
guy's a cool guy right it's funny as you
age the real tough guys they'll say run
when you get into a fight what so for
example I hired this one guy who is a
worked Secret Service or president and
his job is to protect me and I'm
interviewing him he's a little guy not a
big guy he's not six five you know what
the typical body goes at six five 350
pounds offensive line This Guy's 510
maybe 160 pounds I said dude do you know
how to fight do you know how to do like
what what are you gonna do if somebody
says let me tell my job is he says if
you want to hire a big guy for
commercial to be you know physically big
I'm the wrong guy because that guy's
going to fight the opponents he says my
job is to make sure you're safe I'm
going to show you how to run the facet
run we're gonna he says we're going to
run if you want to live we got to get
your wife and kids out we're running
that's an interesting perspective Jocko
fight breaks out you run you don't go
and fight Okay so
right now this whole thing with military
industrial complex all right listen guys
let's create a proxy war let's get
Ukraine to be the proxy behind closed
doors let's hop them out to go against
Russia because if [__] hits the fan and
this thing gets worse guys we can really
make some money okay fine so you can
create and instigate then you make
billions
part nobody thinks about is at an older
age when you got wife and kids if you
get into a stupid fight somebody may
have a gun
and that gun means your life is over
with in this instance what if you cross
the line too much to the point where
this man is publicly being humiliated
and all of a sudden he says okay you
want to go there no problem guy fine
let's roll the dice here's what we're
doing next and it's not 500 000 people
it's not 5 million people next thing you
know boom 50 million 100 million most
people don't think that's possible it's
like when you sell like I've been to
life insurance industry 20 years when
you saw life insurance like you'll hear
a lot of attend these Macho guys will
say I don't need life insurance I'm 38.
two years that I get a phone call from
the wife remember that one time my
husband didn't want to buy he died no
I'm not I don't have anything left I
don't know what to do okay we hear
stories like that how close and how
possible is it like you know okay a lot
of people will say stuff on podcasts and
shows you've been in the military
you I stand corrected not a major
Lieutenant Colonel right you've been to
uh uh Iraq you've been to Kuwait you've
been part of a lot of these
conversations realistically How likely
is it that this thing can get very ugly
now that we're willing to entertain the
idea giving these guys f-16s exactly
that that decision uh will further
escalate it we are the Doomsday Clock
that's reported every year we are closer
to midnight now than ever before
the question of likelihood and how
possible it is very possible and we are
in a position where it is very likely
and becoming even more likely the more
this war is escalated and uh the longer
it goes on and it's we're facing two
great risks here number one is the
scenario you're talking about if Putin
finds himself in a position where he
feels like he has nothing else to lose
and he is facing this existential threat
it's not a matter of guessing they have
already said they will
retain the right to deploy nuclear
weapons how where who remains to be seen
that Prospect is very real the second
prospect that is just as real and
perhaps just as if not more dangerous is
a situation where there's a
miscalculation or there is an
unintentional spark that causes that uh
that to occur we saw this through the
Soviet Cold War there were the risk of
nuclear war and nuclear weapons being
deployed because of misunderstandings
miscommunications miscalculations we see
something coming in in the radar and we
thought it was a nuclear weapon there
were so many so many close calls where
nuclear weapons were almost launched
because of mistakes rather than out of
intention so in both of those situations
whether intentional or unintentional
it's not outside of the realm of
possibility that we could find ourselves
tomorrow in a week a month or a year
facing the reality of a nuclear attack
and nuclear war the nuclear fallout that
comes after the blast the nuclear winter
that comes after that that kills all the
crops and takes away people's ability to
to live the gravity of this
um is difficult to describe because it
is so immeasurable
so so for 2024 uh I wrote a question
down here for you I said if you ran
today or you advise someone who rented
it I don't think you have any plans of
running is that fair to say the word
okay so if you Reign today or you advise
someone so let's just say the Santa
Scott some of these guys call you and
they're like look just as a person I
want to get some counsel from you what
would you say would be top three issues
to run for today like the other day
President Biden said the most uh biggest
enemy to America's white supremacist
which is very weird we're going through
all the stuff right now you want me to
be worried about white supremacists okay
fine maybe it's a top 50 issue it's
definitely not a top five or let alone
number one issue that we have
we know military-industrial complex is
one Ukraine Russia totally get that what
else would you put as a top five issue
we should be paying attention to yeah I
mean this this issue we're talking about
certainly is at the top of the list uh I
think the second issue is um is
immigration and securing our borders we
cannot have a nation without secure
borders uh we are seeing the
consequences of President Biden's open
border policy that's impacting us uh in
in just about every way we see the
National Security threats of of having
an open border people literally
streaming across the border from all
around the world without any kind of
vetting or background that we don't know
who's in our country right now we don't
know what kind of threats uh they may be
posing there's obviously the economic
impact the social welfare system impact
there are so many layers uh of of
negative consequences that come from
their policy and the third would be
focusing on on bringing our economy back
focusing on on actually truly supporting
and investing in you know our small
businesses the the people that are often
touted as the number one Employers in
the country and yet have the hardest
time starting and staying uh in business
is actually focusing on what is in the
best interest of the American people
rather than uh what they are focusing on
which is themselves uh and their power
um to the detriment of the country I
think central to all of this just to to
wrap it up
um in a foundational and fundamental way
is
truly supporting and defending our
freedom and civil liberties because we
are seeing that erosion in so many
different ways without our freedom
without our civil liberties we lose we
really lose what is it the heart of what
it means to be an American in this
country where would you put climate on
that list because I think at one point
you were a proponent of the green new
dude no I never was actually and got
some some crap from the Democratic party
for it I'm a strong environmentalist I I
have is why I ran for office in Hawaii
uh in the first place back in 2002
protecting clean water preserving
natural resources preserving our Open
Spaces conservation of those
uh resources is essential uh you know
advocating for and promoting things like
regenerative Farming versus factory
farms like actually making sure that
this planet that we live on can stick
around and you know help us help us
survive is uh is incredibly important
unfortunately what we're seeing with
this this climate change movement is uh
something that really isn't even
addressing all of these things that are
essential for us to be able to exist uh
and survive what about the uh what part
of the inflation reduction act that was
the largest investment in climate change
that we've ever done did you think that
was a good move what are your thoughts
on that no no I I oppose that
legislation because it was had nothing
to do with inflation reduction first of
all so it was sold on a lie
um and so funny and uh marketing really
I think that's literally all it was and
they couldn't even stick with their own
story on it they kept on calling it
exactly that the greatest climb oh no
wait sorry sorry people care about
inflation let's just call it the
inflation reduction but there was a
component of it whatever it was 200
billion dollars that was dedicated to
climate issues was that something you
were navigated to
I don't see how I I did not see how uh
what they were advocating for would
actually address these these basic
environmental concerns that are very
real uh in this country
I think a lot of people who are
advocating for for that for those things
uh if you look at um their own personal
personal life decisions there's a lot of
hypocrisy there too I think the reason
why Adam's asking that question is
because he's deeply concerned with the
humidity in Miami and he was hoping you
wanted to do something about it yeah so
but that's you know that's what it is in
Hawaii it's you know so out here so by
the way tell us I just want to mention
on on the climate change question
um what's the name of the author who
wrote Jurassic Park
famous author Michael Christ Michael
Crichton he wrote a book and I I can't
remember the title right now but he
wrote a book like 20 years ago uh
Fiction it's a novel uh but it was about
exactly what's happening today where
just like we have the
military-industrial complex he didn't
call it this but it was kind of like the
climate change industrial complex of
people manipulating information and
narratives and quote-unquote scientific
data in order to support their own
industry essentially and uh anyway it's
it's a fascinating book and the date of
fear yes okay it's almost like the
climate change version of 1984 yeah
almost and it's just it was in I I just
I just read it uh I listened to a lot of
audiobooks while I worked out listening
it really is because you you know
there's some you know it's a novel uh so
there's there's some action there's some
Thriller Thriller stuff in there but
when you look at the heart of it uh it's
just one of those eye-opening and kind
of insightful things just so you know
how Pat rules he just purchased the book
right now
I want to learn from Tulsi that's why
she's here with us not trying to live in
a state of curiosity in the in the area
of it's officially bought so curious
you're welcome Michael Crichton
just got 15 more dogs so so curiosity in
a following area we had a conversation
with Buck Sexton and Clay Travis we talk
about endorsements okay like the power
of endorsements and what it means etc
etc okay so uh uh how much value is
there in getting these endorsements okay
so the weight of an endorsement for
example you get it from a heavyweight
politician a president a media Mogul
right you know like a Oprah Winfrey or a
musk or someone like that or an
entrepreneur hey Buffett a Bezos and a
musk or something like a Mark Cuban or
Triple Threat like a must that's got all
three sides influencers but hey you know
podcasts broken hey you know Ben Shapiro
hey you know uh uh all these other guys
that got their influence Logan Paul even
some of these other guys that are doing
what they're because nowadays they're
getting them Hollywood stars like The
Rock Dwayne Johnson military General
coming and backing you up how much power
in influence is there in these types of
endorsement or is it just marketing it's
not really I think it depends it depends
on the person it depends on their
reasoning
um yeah it really depends and it depends
on you know I would say like Joe Rogan
for example he has a very obviously
hugely influential and is a very loyal
following and and uh he and I you know
he found I think over the last few years
especially how the things that he says
really do you have a direct impact no
question
you know I've also heard people say uh
you know that they candidates say that
they would shun an endorsement from a
Beyonce or a big celebrity figure
because that just has well you're just
one of those elitists who I can't relate
to as an everyday American and so that
actually ends up having even though you
know she's like the most powerful
talented musician singer in the world uh
I've heard candidates say well actually
no I don't want those kinds of
endorsements because it sends the wrong
message you know I mean I think I think
every one of these things has
um its own you know pros and cons and I
don't think there's kind of a cookie
cutter uh impact some some are hugely
consequential and others not and others
have a negative consequence how much you
think a muscus by the way Jay-Z and
Beyonce just bought the most expensive
house in California and Malibu for 200
million dollars close it this week wow
it's a two-bedroom apartment
[Laughter]
it's on the water though right
the musk in the how much weight does
that carry you think it's a big weight
especially for somebody let's just say
on the middle center right
um I think it certainly carries weight
for people who who like what he's doing
and and who follow him I think it would
also you know how much weight does it
carry would depend on how much of his
own skin in the game he's if he just
says oh yeah I like this guy and then he
never says anything again has a
different uh has a different consequence
than him actually doing what you were
talking about in the beginning hey
you're a person of influence a person of
means if you really want to see this
change how much are you willing to put
your own skin in the game to actually
make it happen
got it so if he was let's just say to a
pack on Trump or whoever and he put up
or DeSantis whoever and he put up
something like 100 million dollars is
that a way of others saying damn if he's
going like that with this person there's
got to be something we don't know do you
think that carries a very big stick very
big influence that would that would make
a big impact that would make a big
impact it's amazing what a hundred
million dollars would do these days you
know if it'll buy some influence I mean
Bloomberg tried to do it it didn't do
anything for him but you know I'm just
thinking about how much these things
because you know a lot of people this
person got endorsed by that person this
person got endorsed by that person
I think Bloomberg though is is kind of
an example again I don't you know he was
running for president at the same time I
never got to know him at all but what I
saw on the ground was uh people were
very happy to take his money yeah didn't
mean they supported him didn't mean they
voted for him I thought you were going
to say what I saw on the ground was a
six inch lifter like this I'm sorry I
thought that's where you were going with
it and then you took a left turn I went
right my apologies was this 100 million
dollars for his own campaign or was that
okay gotcha but there's a big difference
between putting 100 million dollars
backing yourself versus yes and Elon
backing a DeSantis for example there's a
big difference there yeah no no but I
think no no he spent 100 million dollars
on biting guys he spent in Florida no I
I he spent a hundred million dollars
interesting
yes that's what I was I know he spent a
lot of money on himself but I'm talking
specifically with Biden okay Durham
report comes out okay
mainstream media
nobody even talks about it everybody
else is like wait a minute did you guys
just see what happened here okay this is
a real thing what was in the Durham
report that people need to pay more
attention to what I did see first of all
from uh you know Talking Heads on MSNBC
I I believe even CNN was uh they did
talk about it actually maybe not much
but what they did say about it was a
complete dismissal uh that it was
nothing of value that it uh should not
be paid attention to that it was just
more lies and more bias
etc etc completely dismissing it and not
actually addressing uh the substance of
it the one person who I would say was
pretty fair in his analysis was Jake
Tapper on CNN when he talked about it uh
he had a he had a fair interview on what
was in the report what wasn't in the
report and is it his own statement was
that this was essentially an exoneration
of Donald Trump
um Fox News covered it obviously uh and
I think overall the the major takeaway
for people who don't have time to read
the report didn't didn't catch it in the
news is that it it absolutely exposed uh
the FBI the FBI is being weaponized uh
essentially by the Hillary Clinton Camp
uh Barack Obama and his team were aware
of it to go after uh and investigate and
try to undermine Donald Trump's
candidacy and presidency I want to read
this from Washington examiner May 19
Durham report five key takeaways from
the bombshell findings into Trump Russia
investigation
no proper basis to launch Crossfire
hurricane Durham report claims that
Crossfire hurricane the Trump Russia
investigation lacked a proper Foundation
due to the FBI's failure to conduct key
Source interviews review its own
databases and apply standard analytical
tools to Hillary Clinton connections the
report indicates instances of FBI
favoritism towards Hillary Clinton
including defensive briefings ending and
investigation due to illicit campaign
funds and restricted probes into the
Clinton Foundation Mark Elias the
Clinton campaign's general counsel and
Michael sussman's his former Perkins
Cole Law Firm colleagues are criticized
for the roles with Fusion GPS and
stealer still does here and then third
dacian Russian disinformation the report
uncovers the use of unverified Steel
report of Pfizer applications targeting
former Trump campaign associate Carter
page intelligence might have compromised
steel sources and highlights that Igor
danchenko provided steel with rumor and
speculation number four no collusion the
Durham's report suggests that absence of
tangible collusion evidence at the onset
of Crossfire hurricane while the FBI
continuously upheld claims from steel uh
disregarding contradiction information
last but not least no further crimes
charged the report culminated in only
one guilty plea by ex-fbi lawyer Kevin
Klein Smith for document falsification
despite charges against Sussman and
danchenko and Report found no further
criminal offenses the reason why I'm
bringing this up is because back in 2016
this is what Hillary Clinton said about
you
Russia's grooming her to be the third
party candidate she's the favorite of
the Russians they have a bunch of sites
and Bots and other ways of supporting
her so far just like Jill Stein did back
in 2016. you responded to Queen of War
mongers embodiment of corruption and
personification of the rat that has
sickened the Democratic party for so
long I mean you went gentle at her the
way you did so the reason why I'm kind
of putting these two together is the
following a reason one a lot of smart
people believed that Trump was tied to
Russia a lot of educated people a lot of
people that are professionals they have
degrees they're smart they're like yeah
you know what he is in for three years
most of America actually believed it and
I know you try to sue Hillary Clinton uh
uh uh and I think that whole thing back
and forth you know seven months later
whatever happened with that but now Fox
pays 787 you know to uh dominion and
there's another 1.7 billion or 2.1
billion that's right now
smartmatic I mean
are you kidding me like do you not have
any more where I feel like this is the
part of Republicans where they screw up
you have something like this that just
came out why not get lawyered up create
a fund of Americans that would want to
fund this hey this is how I would do it
listen guys I'm not doing this alone I'm
not going to pay the legal fees it's
going to cost a lot of money you really
want this if this hits 50 million
dollars on GoFundMe
we're gonna go get the best lawyers and
investigate every single thing Clinton's
ABC CBS NBC at CNN everybody did we will
investigate it and we will show
documentation of all our expenses but we
will not do it until it hits 50 million
you want it to pay up pay some money to
go for me why isn't that happening I
feel like a lot of American people are
sitting there saying dude all this [__]
show some backbone go fight give a loss
or do something about it you're not
doing nothing about it yeah what are
your thoughts on this I mean it's a
great question that without any response
or true accountability there's no reason
why this kind of thing wouldn't happen
again there's a reason why people
believed all of it it's a reason why
people you know when Hillary Clinton
said that to me my my first reaction was
like this is this is so insane it's
laughable were you expecting it at all
when she said that no I wasn't uh came
out of left field is like were you here
behind closed doors she was saying I
knew that there were there were murmurs
okay because because I mean look you
know look at look at what happened to
Donald Trump it became the go-to line
when they didn't like what someone was
saying it was automatically like okay
these are Russian talking points or it
became kind of that thing I was not
expecting uh you know the former
Secretary of State former U.S senator
former first lady uh to spend the time
talking about me uh in this light and
smearing me and trying to cancel me but
the reason why people and as I
campaigned and I went out and talked to
people I was confronted
sometimes angrily sometimes very
emotionally this woman I'll never forget
I was at a very small uh little
Democratic party event in a small rural
County in South Carolina and this woman
who was the the chair of that County
Democratic party came up to me there's
probably 50 people in the room
and uh she she put her hands on my
shoulder and she was so serious and her
eyes are almost welling up with tears
and she said I need to look you in the
eyes and ask you
are you working for Putin
not joking it was a very uh you know she
obviously she took her role seriously
she took her leadership seriously this
was something that was really really
concerning to her and it it you know I I
looked her directly back in the eye and
I said I love my country so much so that
I'm willing to die
to protect and defend the United States
of America and the American people does
that answer your question she's
but the fact that it impacted her so
deeply
shows uh not only again the influence of
the of of the clintons Hillary Clinton
but but what is that machine why is it
that these things become believable why
are they never questioned why is there
never a request for evidence why didn't
Axelrod in that conversation say oh
really interesting what evidence do you
have to prove that point these things
were never asked in the mainstream media
they just repeat the talking point over
and over just as they did during the
Trump campaign in the Trump presidency
without actually asking for evidence why
aren't they asking because they don't
care
they repeat the talking point enough to
the point where people believe well this
is fact I heard it on CNN I heard it on
MSNBC I heard it from Hillary Clinton
how could it not be true and I've I've
had so many conversations with people
like even people who know me personally
and they are like you know people on CNN
live like but why would they lie they
probably just got bad information they
didn't mean to like no they're there's
nefarious intent here to manipulate the
American people to believe certain
things so that then they take action uh
in the interest of that status quo the
hunter Biden laptop the 51 senior uh
former intelligence officials there's
there's unfortunately many examples of
how these lies are created spread and
perpetuated in order to achieve a
specific outcome and and you're right
Pat if there's no accountability if
there's no action taken
these are some of the things that we
need to be continuing to look out for as
we head into this next election that
would be that would be one of my rally
cries I would say listen here's what
we'll do you want us to find out more
about this I want you to also put some
you know put your money where your mouth
50 bucks 100 bucks you're not giving it
to me you're giving it to the
contribution let's go figure this thing
out and we'll go get the best lawyers
but uh uh uh yeah obviously you're
qualified to talk about this that's why
I wanted to ask you about it on how much
impact that if a woman's coming up to
you saying I gotta look at you in your
eyes to see if you're an asset too who
broke my heart to hear her say that
because I could tell it was really it
was hurting her
it tells you propaganda works it's very
effective were you going to say
something I I just wanted to understand
why do you think Hillary Clinton
targeted you of all people of anyone in
politics what was her goal targeting you
and labeling you a Russian asset
broadly I was someone who over the years
even as she was Secretary of State under
President Obama was very outspoken and
very critical of her her decisions her
influence uh obviously critical of the
president at the time of some of those
foreign policy decisions
um
when I left as Vice chair of the DNC to
endorse Bernie Sanders because of his
position on foreign policy speaking out
very clearly uh and critically on
Hillary Clinton's foreign policy fairly
certain uh that that put me on on their
uh list which I'm told is a very very
real thing
um
being somebody that they couldn't uh
control and who had the audacity to
challenge them uh is is my guess is why
she has chosen uh on more than one
occasion to to try to smear me it was
interesting one of the uh one of the
interviews that I did I think it was
actually on MSNBC right after I left as
Vice chair of the DNC
um the host of the show and I don't
remember who exactly was the host of the
show it was it was right before a
presidential primary debate they said
Tulsi aren't you afraid of the clintons
and what they might do
and it was live television it couldn't
it wasn't a pre-tape and I smiled I said
no I'm not
good for you things happen in this and I
like being alive by the way
I think we all do it every day is a
blessing
um oh my God out of curiosity
nothing to do with the war nothing to do
with Ukraine Russia just what are your
thoughts on Vladimir Putin and his
mindset these days
uh I I don't I don't his mindset I think
when we look at from a foreign policy
perspective I'm not going to pretend to
claim to know what's going through his
mind but I think if we look from the
outsider's view in as you have uh NATO
continuing to expand continuing to
surround uh Russia you look back to what
Putin has said has been his most concern
from the very greatest concern from the
very beginning which was uh not being
surrounded on all sides by NATO armed
countries and feeling that threat so
this this latest development of of
um what looks to be the United States
providing f-16s either directly or
indirectly to Ukraine this is going to
be a very serious escalation uh in this
war that that will lead could lead to
those disastrous consequences nuclear
that we're talking about the reason I
asked is there's a large contingency of
people on the right who actually have
higher approval ratings of Putin than
they do of Biden which is concerning I
get that you know if you're American
whether you like Biden or like Trump you
should support our president
as a primary focal point rather than a
Russian
dictator yeah why do you think people
are so fast I won't even begin I won't
even begin I have no I have no idea but
but I think it's more important I I
don't think we should blindly support
anybody
period I think it's more important for
us as Americans regardless of political
party to stand together on our ideals
and principles uh that that we celebrate
and that we should cherish in this
country those principles of freedom and
our god-given rights that are enshrined
in the Constitution those are things
that
um they are under attack they are under
threat and they are things unfortunately
that we cannot take for granted at this
time when people are saying well hey
maybe the First Amendment uh you know no
longer applies that it's okay to silence
and censor uh and cancel uh certain
people's uh Speech these are things that
that we used to all be able to agree on
and and even something as sacred as the
first amendment is is no longer sacred
unfortunately and
um it should concern everyone I'll give
you my response okay I respect anybody
that loves their family defends their
Heritage defends their denomination
whatever Faith they have
and fights for their country to protect
their people and not giving deals to
people on the outside that they're for
sale
I don't have to like you uh but I can
respect you in the industry business
you've been I've been competing for a
long time guys sold out their people all
the time they would sell their agents to
get money on the side and nobody knew
about they would sell their employees
they would sell everything they could in
a way of running their agency they got
you know 5 000 agents hey I'll give you
a million dollars if you also sell this
nobody knew about it we never sold out
uh he has protected his country as a
nationalist of Russia
that's something you gotta respect
unfortunately in America you know my
sister sent me the national anthem for
Germany okay I want to read this to you
this is Germany's national anthem okay I
don't know if you just send it to me
this was a few days ago it says Germany
Germany above everyone above everyone in
the world guess what uh Deutschland
Deutschland Uber Alice Uber Alice in
dervelt okay you know somebody must say
that's Hitler I totally get it but in
America we're embarrassed to read our
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America or you know our
prayers that we have these things that
we did were embarrassed the fact that
America was number one for so long and I
respect anybody that is proud of whoever
they are by the way I don't have to
agree with your political philosophies
but I respect the fact that you uh
respect where you come from that's a
whole different conversation I don't
want to get into that part that's just
my thoughts on uh Russia and FYI no we
shouldn't be supportive of that guy
America First is what it needs to be and
this criticism that Americans are
apologizing about being America First is
the most pathetic thing ever can you
imagine you having to apologize for
being married to your wife and every day
I have to apologize for your kids you
have to apologize for your parents you
have to apologize what do you mean I
have to apologize I'm an Assyrian I'm
our man I'm proud I'm from Iran I'm
proud that I was born and raised in Iran
I'm proud to be an American I'm proud to
be a veteran I'm proud I'm proud We
ought to be proud some people are not
proud of being Americans and that's
pathetic in my eyes now let's go to the
last couple topics that we have great
question Adam
here's the last couple topics one of
them uh is uh musk and Cuban and what's
been going back and forth with you know
Cuban said a couple comments about
months I I miss that okay no problem
I'll read it to you and then you know
maybe even an open-ended question I'm
sure you're kind of following what's
going on with uh uh what do you call it
Tim
musk's recent hire the CEO yeah uh some
are happy about it some are concerned
World economic forum
you know is he going this direction is
he going that direction he does an
interview the next day the guy asked the
question I don't know if you've seen
this or not where there's a 10 second
pause can you pull this up where he says
I'll say whatever I want to say Great
Clips
what do you what do you what's the what
title should you put to find this clip
with a 10 second uh I do what I want a a
musk uh uh you know which one I'm
talking about I think that's it can you
zoom in a little bit to see if you see
the how long is it two minutes and 40s
no don't do that one because you're
gonna have to find the 10 second clip
maybe in the search put 10 seconds
in the search put 10 seconds for this to
come up 10 seconds to come up uh okay
well you look for it I want to ask Tulsi
Tulsi what do you think about the higher
of his recent CEO I think her name is I
want to say Linda uh what are your
thoughts on the recent CEO higher
I mean based on what I know is is
extremely superficial
um I yeah I've read a little bit of the
top lines but people's concerns about
her associations or or things that she
said or spoken on what's interesting is
that the concerns that have come from
people who say that they are
conservatives are talking about you know
she part of the globalist movement Etc
et cetera
um on the Democrat side or on the
mainstream media side the concerns they
pointed out was that she follows a lot
of conservatives on Twitter and so I
just thought it was interesting that you
have both sides finding reasons to
criticize her I don't know her I don't
know what you know what are the
qualities that that Elon Musk saw in her
to bring her on the table uh to to bring
her uh on board great let's play this
clip this is a clip of a recent
interview he did and uh uh his response
is just powerful go for it uh
we gotta you gotta play the question
Princess Bride
the short version doesn't have the
question in it yeah what was the
question do you remember the question
was essentially uh how concerned are you
that your personal ideology your
personal tweets your memes everything
that you do
um might affect the stock price of Tesla
uh and you know the ramifications of
that sure this is in regards to his
tweet calling George Soros Magneto
gotcha that was fact check though right
that he go ahead uh
long pause there's a scene in The
Princess Bride powerful great movie
great um
where he confronts the person who killed
his father
he says
I
offer me money
offer me power
I don't care
so you just don't care
if you want to share what you have to
say I'll say what I want to say and if
if if
the consequence of that is losing money
so be it
okay
no Flinch gotta love it this freaking
guy powerful yeah I mean uh look I I
hope he stays in this state there's a
lot of concerns uh I also have about
this new CEO uh but you know he ran a
poll the other day hey uh bad higher
good higher let's wait and see I think
bad good hire was six percent bad hire
was like 24 and let's wait and see
what's like 60 plus percent obviously
the right answer for all of us is let's
wait and see we're gonna find out what's
going to happen and she's just an
advertising person and to come from
there defending kind of BlackRock and
some of that stuff was a little bit
concerning so let's talk ESG just on
that clip I just want to say you know I
think we earlier we were talking about
what what do people value
you know that says a lot about a person
what what is most important what what
does he value obviously he's a business
guy yeah wildly successful he's good at
what he does but when it comes right
down to it what does he actually value I
learned that he values awesome movies
the princess brides I mean if you've
never seen that movie I've seen it a few
times
what a powerful movie hundred of giants
shout out to him yeah
gotta love him though like to see like
different but by the what's your
favorite movie now that he recorded a
movie do you have a favorite movie
um it's a it's a mini series called
Banda Brothers
of course at World War II Tom Hanks it
is uh it is Tom Hanks it I've I've over
the years seen it a number of times I
first I think the first time I saw it is
actually going through officer candidate
School in the Army and we had to uh over
whatever many weeks it was we watched an
episode and we had to write an essay on
the lessons of leadership either
successful or failures of leadership
that came from each episode that was
based on on World War II favorite actor
or actress
Denzel Washington really yeah favorite
Denzel movie
I can't think of a bad one come on give
me the favor I'm so bad there's one that
Pat wants you know I want to see what
she's gonna do the one where he plays
the bad cop oh okay yeah ridiculous
movie yeah King Kong with Eva yeah yeah
that's that's definitely up there oh
yeah go ahead say what you're what's on
your mind you know your favorite for me
movies of Vengeance Redemption Revenge
these are like you know it's it's like
Skittles to a 12 year old who loves
candy so what's your favorite Man on
Fire is with Denzel to meet us like John
Q the scene with him and his kid in the
doctor you know like he buries me you
know not the other ass you feel the tuck
he has a great actor yeah uh but yeah
all-time movie I would probably say you
know notebook Gone With the Wind I'm
just kidding but but notebook notebooks
I've never seen that movie you know that
I've never seen it really yeah Tulsi
you're missing out you're missing out
what do you want it's actually a very
political movement it's a very do you go
for money or do you go for your beliefs
yes that's what it's about interesting
uh but okay so
with uh in regards to ESG
um Dei CEI all this stuff you know the
other day we're kind of sitting around
uh and we're looking at the next episode
to shoot and we're seeing the ties with
esgd ICI and then you look at CEI that
the corporate equality index you know
who's behind it who's given the scoring
are you concerned about the direction
they're going with esgd ICI you think
this is going to work or you think
eventually people are going to be like
listen the hell are you doing with this
Bud Light this was a dumb move what are
you doing Ford Raptor yeah do you even
make Hollywood you just made an
announcement that a third of everybody
you hire has to be from an
underrepresented community and I have to
hire a black a Hispanic a woman a LGB a
this a that and even Richard Dreyfus and
actors are coming out and saying this
doesn't make any sense do you think this
is eventually going to be exposed as a
terrible idea or do you think this is
going to be used as a way to weaponize
small business owners and S P 500
companies
both I think that it is already being
it's the fact that you've got some of
the biggest actors uh in history uh or
in our in our time at least uh actually
you know maybe for the first time coming
out and speaking out against this stuff
is pretty powerful and I think it is
starting to expose
um the hypocrisy and the the insanity of
it uh and I think there's already
evidence showing how it is uh being
manipulated and weaponized so they talk
about these things with these very
altruistic idealistic intentions and
objectives you know we're working for uh
Equity without you know the clip of of
of
um Bernie Sanders on Bill Maher the
conversation they had about Equity
versus equality was was very telling
when Bill Maher had to describe to
Bernie you know what what Equity really
means and he said so what is it Equity
or equality and Bernie says well
equality
um there there are these acronyms that
are being thrown out by people as as
though it's for the best public good
many of them don't even know what it
actually means and we've seen with the
SG some of the scoring and things that
have been done that are that are uh show
that it's being manipulated for um
other interests than the public good
they are claiming it to be so I think
both are already starting to be uh
exposed
as we speak that's good you know the
sooner the better because it's not
really making people leaders make the
right decision is this a clip you're
talking about the equal quality exactly
what this is yeah I actually want to see
it I've never seen this yeah are we
confusing a quality of opportunity with
trying to guarantee equity and outcomes
okay that's interesting because I heard
this word Equity is coming to the
language in the last few years and
before that we didn't hear it a lot and
I think a lot of people hear equity and
they hear equality I think it's the same
word and it's not the same word in the
same I believe this is concept how would
you differentiate between equity and
equality yeah
well equality we talk about uh
I don't know what the answer is
you know uh equality is equality of
opportunity all right we live in a
society we want all people right to have
whatever color your skin is equity I
think is more guarantee of outcome is it
not
I mean I think so I think okay so which
do you come which side do you come down
on
equality equality yeah okay
boys any comment on that one I just
don't know if that's the that's the
definition of difference
oh my God that was great it's good it's
very straightforward and and I think
he's writing a lot of people don't know
the difference but they're using these
words because it's the thing that
everybody's saying and it's the popular
thing of the moment did you ever think
there would come a time where you know
the feminist woman has tried so hard to
you know get to a point where it's men
and women are equal right we want equal
pay
we want you to watch WNBA whether you
like it or not we want the same amount
of viewers you know we want you to uh uh
pay us the same amount of money we want
you to give us the same amount of
respect all this stuff and then they get
so wild and crazy that even the feminist
movement ends up losing to men because
they allow men to join their camp and
just call themselves did you ever think
this state was going to come no
how do we get here this is a little
weird for me how do we get here it is
I mean you know it is it is it is this
mental illness that is taking over our
society where things that are not real
are being sold as real things that are
not true are being sold as true and it's
this exercise of power and this is this
is the underlying danger that that sits
beneath all of these crazy things is
that
those who are in power across you know
government not all of these different
entities are putting us in a position
where we are being told that we just
have to comply and go along with
whatever they say that there is no room
for critical thinking or questioning or
common sense or science or biology even
that whatever they say goes and we we
have to just fall fall in line and that
that's the real danger that uh that is
the common thread with all of these
crazy examples
um that we're seeing that that aren't
just they're they're not theoretical
it's not just for the sake of arguments
we're actually seeing the very real
impacts on kids on our society and our
communities don't they call it the woke
mind virus do you think that's an
appropriate name for this I do
what's next though I guess you know we
had a gentleman here I think I can say
gentlemen Frank from uh gays against
rumors and we're having a great
conversation with them and I said you
know so we talked about the
uncomfortable conversations that nobody
wants to talk about because God knows it
could lose votes and they can lose this
and this and that I'm like look you know
at first you know when when somebody
certain you know I'm gay or I'm lesbian
I'm this okay there was a certain
connotation there was a certain like hey
you know this person this is not a
normal behavior but we said you know
military don't ask don't tell I was in a
unit with a couple guys that were gay
it's very easy to tell when you're in
the shower it's like hey bro you okay is
everything okay with you seem a little
excited and then you find out six months
later now now I know why you're always
fired up okay you should have told us so
we would have had different schedules
for showers I'm fired up Pat I'm ready
to go a little little awkward you're
like dude you know I don't know what
he's seeing that he's so excited about
and we would always talk about it
finally we laughed about it but you know
it was a don't ask don't tell type of a
situation today we have to salute we
have to do this we have to do that and
then all of a sudden the more and more
and more
we kept buying into this concept but
it's normal but it's normal but it's
normal it's normal and I got a book
upstairs saying it's normal
millions of copies sold it's a book for
a 10 year olds in school on how boys
have sex with boys and how girls have
sex with girls and how boys have sex
with girls and all this stuff okay it's
not the ABC it's the other one it's
called it's normal something like that
but I asked this question because
when the camera's off people are willing
to talk about this more openly when the
camera's on everybody's a little bit
careful about it it's perfectly normal
that's the book everybody's a little bit
careful about it because what if this
and what if that and what if this right
isn't the reason why we kind of got here
where Sports Illustrated I'm not I have
no problem with Martha Stewart she
actually looks good for an 81 year old
go to the other one yes yeah apparently
81 I thought she looks great for 81.
respect respect but do the guy the guy
that's wearing this this uh one piece uh
uh do you know which one I'm talking you
know which one I'm talking about
Adidas I think it was Adidas is it
Adidas can you go to Adidas um
folks just bear for you know it's it's a
little bit uh uh uh strange this model
uh anyways I guess I'll come I will find
it here to picture do you think it's a
little strange that the more and more
and more accepting we become gradually
the next thing they could pitch is the
fact that a 44 year old ends up being
with somebody who is 13 years old well
guess what that's just what it is that's
who they accept and you know
it's normal it's normal that you know
it's they we should accept the fact that
they love each other and some people say
you're out of your mind this will never
happen we'll never get there nobody ever
thought we're gonna get here well that's
all it's already happening it's already
happening the normalization of
pedophilia the fact that there is such a
term as a minor attracted person oh my
God the fact that that is a term that's
being used and assigned to people who
are adults who are quote unquote
attracted to minors yeah that's a
pedophile
that's a crime against a child and those
criminals should be locked up and kept
away from children how are Democrats
supporting that though that that's my
point I have not heard a single Democrat
in Congress in the house or the Senate
speak out against this nonsense and
their response is always like oh it's a
non-issue like these things only affect
a handful of people they don't actually
speak to or address what is happening
and how we have people who are teachers
who are out there and on there on social
media saying I'm a minor attracted
person I shouldn't be discriminated
against any of these people who are
entrusted with the well-being and safety
of our kids so this progression that
you're talking about uh is is very very
real and the fact that it is uh
happening not only with the acceptance
but encouragement of the very same
people who are totally fine with these
books that are sexualizing kids as young
as five six seven years old uh
I'm not a parent but parents everywhere
people who care about children
everywhere should should be stepping up
and speaking out about against it can I
ask you a question on this topic so back
to that back to the
lgbtqia plus all this stuff Dave
Chappelle has an amazing take on this
amazing joke and he basically gives the
metaphor that they're you know they're
all in a car together they're heading in
the same direction they all have
completely different agendas yeah like
the L is different from the B versus the
G versus the T and he basically you know
summarizing this is like the G's driving
because that's the gay guy and he's
driving he's the man whatever and then
the the L is sitting in the front seat
and she's doing her thing and everybody
loves the L's because you know who
doesn't like the L's except for the G
because he's like I wouldn't wear that
this whole deal and then the B is in the
back and she's just like listen I'll do
whatever anyone wants in this car but
then you get to the t's and the whole
premise of his joke is like nobody's got
a problem with any of this stuff but
this tea thing
is that's where people are like I don't
what's the T are you a guy or a girl
you're cutting things off you're moving
things around you're a man but you want
to play in women's sports and like and
I'm I'm one of the people that are like
I think that women should be more
outspoken about this I agree so you know
I host another show sawscast and I have
a lot of women on my show and I do a lot
of man on the street interviews and I'll
ask them a series of questions about
money and dating and relationships and
then I'll say hey by the way
uh what are your thoughts on
um biological Men playing in women's
sports and that's the one question that
women are like ah yeah I don't want to
answer that on camera I don't really
want to talk about it and all right cool
next question and then the interview is
over and they're like listen I don't
really want to talk about it but I think
it's really freaking weird and I don't I
don't want to share bathrooms with guys
and you know I just don't want to offend
people and say this stuff on camera but
just between you and me yeah I'm not
comfortable with it I'm like why
wouldn't you say that on camera well you
know cancel culture this that and the
other why do you think young women
specifically are are so afraid to speak
on this topic
I think it is that that power of of uh
self-censorship that has been you know
uh that it's it's kind of a mandate of
self-censorship that if you don't go
along to get along then you will be
canceled and you'll be attacked and
you'll be called names and you will be
smeared uh Bethany Hamilton is a surfer
out of Hawaii you know who I'm talking
about she had her arm [__]
uh when she was a kid still competing uh
on the circuit and uh once the world
surf League announced biological males
will be allowed to compete against women
on the tour she was the only one who had
the courage to speak out she never talks
about politics she is so pleasant so
mellow doesn't get involved with any of
the headlines or anything that goes on
but she recognized that she uh she had a
responsibility uh to speak up and she
did and she got attacked heavily for it
which I think she expected and she she
spoke out in the sweetest kindest most
compassionate way just saying that I'm
not against anyone but this is about
what's fair and what's right for women
on the tour and it's just not right
shortly after that we International
women's day came around and every year
the WSL uh welcomes professional Surfers
men men who want to put the name of a
prominent woman who inspires him on the
back of their jersey for the contest on
that day
I think there were five or six men who
wanted to put Bethany Hamilton's name on
their Jersey that day and the WSL said
no wow you are not allowed to put her
name her name alone on your jersey a
woman's name a woman's name yeah a woman
who has throughout her lifetime exceeded
all of the obstacles put before her and
is thriving as a human being as a
professional Surfer because she had the
audacity to speak out the truth this was
the consequence uh it's good to see I
think I think slowly it's not happening
fast enough but slowly there are more
women who are being directly impacted
inspired by people like Riley Gaines and
Bethany gains the same story is almost
like that just into swimming with Leah
Thomas absolutely and and but they're
inspiring a lot of other women girls to
recognize uh how powerful their voice
can be you know just in case you guys
are looking to buy some gifts for some
friends this is the latest swim swimwear
from Adidas if you wanna
girl if you want to zoom in a little bit
Rob
um that kind of sound a bit I'm so sorry
guys I'm not trying to be funny but
that's a little weird okay I don't care
it's a little weird Okay
um
afford them to try to normalize this
is extremely weird but you know what
this does today it says home women
clothing there we go yep do you know
what this does to them this increases
their CEI score their ESG score right
that's what this does what is this I'm
familiar with disgu not this is a new
one now CEI by the way here's the
craziest thing about CEI CEI is a form
of a uh di you know Dei is what
diversity Equity inclusive the whole
thing CEI is Corporate equality index
and the ones that give the scores to
them is a company called HRC HRC stands
for human rights Hillary Rodham Clinton
HRC is sorry HRC is Human Rights
Campaign here's the crazy part you ready
for this yeah they got started in 84.
you know who funds Human Rights Campaign
George Soros it's funded by open Society
Foundation okay do you know who runs
open Society Foundation
oh so yeah there we go yeah literally
and they come to your company and they
measure the score only 20 people 20
companies have a perfect score of 100
and they'll come back and say Here's
what you need to do to improve they have
a whole structure by the way Workforce
protection Five Points possible no
discrimination of the awoke rating yeah
it's called awoke rating you've not seen
this no yeah it's called the woke rating
okay that's not a joke though this is as
sincere as as real as it gets Rob I'm
going to send this to your computer
if you want to show this Rob iPhone or
I'm going to send it to the I'm going to
send it to your iPhone just to show this
and it will wrap up on this topic here
uh no this is exactly how they are
scoring uh different companies Workforce
protection that gives you Five Points
inclusive benefits 50 points criteria
here includes providing health care for
same-sex couples
supporting an inclusive culture
25 possible points including gender
neutral dress codes and trans-inclusive
restroom facilities policies number four
is Corporate social responsibility you
get 20 points marketing or advertising
to lgbtq Consumers which include Nike
and Bud light's use of transgender
spokesperson Dillon Mulvaney that's
crazy and then number five is
responsible citizenship 25 points uh
deducted if a company gives money to
organizations to primary Mission
includes advocacy against
lgbtq organizations which is not defined
but could include Christian groups wow
uh uh any final thoughts on this uh
Tulsi I'll give you the floor if you got
anything I want to uh I wanna show show
the way things used to be just a few
years ago did you did you see the Levi's
uh skit on SNL uh the the about the moms
about your pants yeah Mom pants yes the
mom pants Oh yes though
because it's a SNL all right about like
Hey we're moms yeah we wear mom pants
well and it was it was all about gender
nude it was it was really pointing out
the the farce of of uh you know
everything that you just talked about
just five years ago SNL made a great
five years ago five years ago SNL made a
great skit about it making fun of Levi's
shapeless genderless pants
um and rightly so yeah Mom pants I got
to go see last question on this topic I
want to ask you a question about just
normal old school traditional women you
know
um it's a political question but you
know yourself you look at Kamala Harris
current VP Hillary Clinton almost
president a lot of people say
AOC could potentially be a candidate in
a handful of years whether you like her
or not
um there's other women that have run
recently Carly fiorino a lot of people
are you know Advocates of Marjorie
Taylor green what have you
um how ready do you think America is for
a female president now
I think America is ready for the right
woman president
some of the uh
I think it's wrong to assume and this is
this has been one of the insulting
things that I've experienced even from
within the Democratic Party is that they
assume uh they this sounds ironic saying
this now that they have reduced women to
our biological parts to say well if
you're a woman you have to support women
that was the whole argument with Hillary
Clinton right for me I didn't support
her and literally I was asked by some of
the most powerful women and influential
women in the country how dare you as a
woman not support this other woman and
my response was how dare you reduce me
to my biological parts and think that I
don't have my own brain my own mind my
own opinions and Views and yet where are
we today now they deny this biological
objective truth that there is such a
thing as a woman at all it's it's just
Madness
the right it's the right person whether
it be a man or woman yes absolutely I
think we we're looking for the right
person we're ready for the right right I
don't think it's we're not you know
Tulsi I got a text message someone's
asking for a referral if a potential
candidate is looking for a potential VP
would you entertain the idea someone's
asking for a referral
I would entertain I would entertain the
idea on the basis of whether or not I
would be able to have an impact a very
real impact on
defending our country both our freedom
and our security and our future I think
you would be one hell of a VP that would
be endless and I think you'd be one hell
of a whatever you choose to do you're a
leader but that would be some wild uh uh
if if that were to happen the draw on
who would be attracted to that person as
a VP oh my God
like check check check check check check
and a True Believer and a backbone and
willing to go against establishment I
kind of like a lot of that stuff well
thank you for that the person is
thankful for your answer as well it's
very good are you saying that you know
she has your endorsement you know that's
uh
she has my endorsement as a human being
I think she's uh she's very necessary
but gank thank you if you enjoyed this
as much as we did we want you to go
subscribe to both her channels one is
the YouTube One link is below as well as
her Rumble one the link is below uh in
description Rob let's put it in
description comment chat all of it as
well as uh the link to her website you
can go to Tulsi
gabbard.com once again Tulsi gabbard.com
uh to get that done and then Adam has
got his event coming up uh with fresh
and fit that we're doing at the live
event if you want to know more details
about this to get registered for that as
well text award sauce cast SOS cast
sauce cast to
310-340-1132 once again three one zero
three four zero one one three two to get
Intel about that it's going to be
himself fresh and fit in a bunch of
girls to debate and argue about the
conversations of red pill men women
they're going to be talking a lot of
smack if you want to be entertained it's
going to be Friday uh June 2nd at 59.90
live again text Awards sauce cast to
310340-1132 uh Tulsi this was amazing
okay guys looking forward to doing it
again very soon yeah look forward to it
thank you take care everybody have a
great weekend bye bye